when we were seeing these stories four
years ago where the left would accuse
the right winger of doing something I'm
like you realize it doesn't matter if
it's true they believe it anyway even
when you can prove it Covington kids
Russia gate hands up don't shoot they
don't care
so what happens in a situation like this
where not only now do we have escalation
not only now do we have you know Elon
Musk saying he's he's afraid he's gonna
die you have the far left outright
saying right Wingers are shooting up
substations in Acts of Terror
one thing I try to do is to when I it
when if and when I come into contact
with people that believe stuff like that
I try to have the same amount of
Amazement when they find out they're
wrong to to go to kind of empathize with
their amazement as they're realizing oh
it wasn't targeted and then I'm like
okay I I get it now and I feel what
you're feeling as opposed to be like you
idiot of course it wasn't targeted just
be there with them while they realize
that they were not seeing the truth